[Music]
Mike Thomas of the New Orleans Saints
took Twitter yesterday to say if Antonio
Brown is really leaving man Pittsburgh
is about to be funny-looking next year
the truth always comes to the light pay
attention he opened up everything for
the passing game and still got his
that's Michael Thomas Saints receiver
Edie bouche it covers the Steelers for
the Pittsburgh post-gazette he's been
all over this Antonio Brown situation
Edie joins us now ad good morning how
are you buddy good morning good well
there's a little bee in the bonnet for
Antonio Brown we saw that tweet
yesterday I instantly thought that there
must be a deal in place to trade him
somewhere do you know what the Steelers
reaction was to Antonio Brown saying
goodbye at a time when there's been no
goodbyes to be said no Mike but I think
you know are true neither president said
it Oh a while ago he said he can't
envision him being on the team next year
so to me this wasn't even news I think
he's gone one way or the other but
didn't are true knee after that try to
maybe pull it back in a little bit I
mean I my take on it was this ad that
Art Rooney initially was putting the for
sale sign out there hoping that multiple
teams would spark an auction and they
get a great offer and they do a deal
they'd finalize at march 13 and
everything moves forward I don't think
they got the offers they liked and I
think at that point you have to act like
you're going to keep the guy to maybe
get the offers you want do you think
that they are entertaining any
possibility of trying to keep him around
I think that III really don't think so
Mike III I'd be surprised if he comes
back I mean you have that domestic
dispute added on to everything else now
and I know some of his teammates have
said they want him back and art said he
would talk to the leadership but I think
this has reached a point of no return so
how do they properly separate when do
you trade him there's a two and a half
million dollar payment that comes due
the fifth day of the league year if the
offers aren't there do you just take
whatever you can get like they did for
Santonio Holmes eight years ago and move
on or do you try to play this out to
maximize your return well I don't know
if you're gonna get anything more after
March 17th is when that two and a half
million is due so you take what what the
best offer provided that's not from the
Baltimore Ravens or Cleveland Browns or
Cincinnati Bengals so and I think it's
safe to say especially since you
mentioned the three teams in the
division they're not gonna cut him
they're gonna trade him somewhere so
they don't have to worry about him
showing up in the AFC North but your
guess is ultimately they're just going
to take the best offer they can get to
get him probably out of the conference
and then just move on yeah I'm like even
I hate to say it but even if that's a
conditional seventh round pick for 2020
you have to move on that there's been
too much drama over the last two years
they didn't make the playoffs last year
they still have a couple good receivers
and they can pick up a third look at
what the England is done with receivers
through the years you don't need future
hall-of-famers necessarily to help you
get to a Super Bowl isn't it though
difficult for the Steelers to accept the
fact that they are in a situation where
they don't have the control that they
usually have over their players they're
one of the organizations that typically
what they say goes we negotiate when we
wanted to go she ate we don't negotiate
when we don't want it to go she ate
these are our terms this is the way we
do things we don't have guaranteed money
beyond the first year of a deal you know
they are very used to setting terms to
the players and not having the players
tell them how it's going to be is it
difficult for the Steelers to give
Antoniou Brown what he wants well I
think it's what they wanted before he
came out said what he wanted Mike and
yes and I will tell you when I was at
the Super Bowl all week people were
coming up to me League people of writers
broadcasters you name it they were
stunned at what was going on in
Pittsburgh over the last year two years
really and it's very on that's what they
were all saying is very unsealer like
but if with Bell and brown gone I
thank most of the drama that evolved
over the last two years will have gone
with them I had came Hayward on set at
the Super Ball he was the first-round
pick in 2011 one year after Antonio
Brown was a sixth rounder and and I said
how does this happen where Antonio Brown
becomes this diva who is always late who
has things done a different way and gets
validated with two long-term contracts
how did the Steelers let it get to this
point cam didn't have a good answer Edie
how did the Steelers let a sixth-round
pick a guy who shouldn't have walked
through the door thinking he's a big
deal
grow into this guy who expects and is
allowed to have a separate set of rules
death by inches is the new coach of the
Denver Broncos said when he was talking
about how you are you clamped down on
this stuff early you can't keep letting
him go do this and giving him more rope
and more rope Mike Tomlin said a couple
years ago and when someone asked him Ron
Cook of our staff how he allowed Antonio
Brown to keep doing stuff and most of it
was on field celebrations before the
celebration rule was eased and getting
penalties like that and throwing fits on
a sideline Mike Tomlin looked at it bran
and said what do you want me to do bench
him so you know they've been able this
in a little in in some ways and you know
there's been a lot of discussion about
Mike Tom and his future in Pittsburgh we
had the 50th anniversary of Chuck Noll
being hired they've been three coaches
in a half century that's all
well-established I feel like that that
reality has become such a part of the
fabric of the organization that that
Mike Talman and whoever the coach would
be right now whoever it is I feel like
there isn't the same fear within the
Steelers organization of getting fired
if you're the head coach is there would
be with any other team is that is that
an accurate assessment and should there
be that healthy fear for any NFL head
coach that hey if you don't do your job
if you don't hold your players
accountable if you don't instill
discipline if you don't get results
you're not going to have a job yeah you
know it's actually Mike it it worked
that way with Bill Cowher you know he
had two years left in his conch
and that's when they normally negotiated
an extension and they didn't do one
after he won a Super Bowl and he went
into that last season and he decided he
didn't want to sign with them because he
felt they didn't negotiate well enough
if that's the way to put it and Mike is
now going into his last two years and he
didn't make the playoffs last year so I
would bet we're not going to see a
contract extension for him and then
he'll have one year left and who knows
what can happen this is a big year for
them in him I think and I think you're
right the dynamic may not be there as it
was with Chuck and Chuck didn't make the
playoffs seven of those last eight years
and there was a stretch for cow at one
point with three years no playoffs and
the Steelers have prided themselves on
that stability but you know when there's
a sense that the team under achieves and
at some point even if you make it to the
playoffs or even if you have a winning
record it's not good enough if you're
not cashing in on that full potential
and delivering championships especially
not the Patriots have six to match the
Steelers add great stuff as always we'll
check out your work at the Pittsburgh
post-gazette and the post cadets website
we'll talk to you again soon all right
there is that boo shet one of our good
friends of the program and fully aware
of what's going on in Pittsburgh and
sure sounds like the Steelers at some
point before March 17 are going to take
the best deal they can get even if it is
a conditional seventh round pick in 2020
just to unload Antonio Brown that's
significant
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports